c'est un peu le candidat démocrate par
défaut notoirement gaffeur pas vraiment
flamboyant ni éloquent zhang en caleçon
et bien connue car en politique depuis
toujours il a quand même réussi à
s'imposer face à une vingtaine d'autres
candidats l'homme du compromis mais
l'adversaire le plus dangereux de touba
y donne pourrait bien n'être joe biden
bîmes est celui des années 90
le politicien aux mains baladeuses en
plein mouvement mitu l'année dernière
oui femme lui avait reproché de les
avoir rendus inconfortables en les
serrant dans ses bras ou en leur faisant
la bise
mais tara reid va beaucoup plus loin
cette ancienne assistante a porté
plainte à la police le mois dernier elle
accuse joe biden de lui avoir fait subir
des attouchements il y a de cela
27 ans je me souviens de ses mains sur
mon buste et sous ma jupe dit elle et
ses doigts qui ne pénétrait des
allégations que le candidat démocrate
nie en bloc
non c'est faux je le dis sans équivoque
affirme-t-il cela ne s'est jamais
produit joe biden assure n'avoir aucun
souvenir de cet incident et soutient que
si la présumée victime a porté plainte à
l'époque il n'y en a pas de traces une
défense qui semble satisfaire pour le
moment les ténors du parti démocrate à
arcueil 30
je suis très à l'aise avec la situation
et j'ai la plus grande estime pour joe
biden dit nancy pelosi
même dans nos jobs a glissé un mot à sa
défense
cela peut être de fausses accusations
dit il cela existe j'ai moi-même été
faussement accusé à de multiples
reprises
mais si les nombreuses allégations
d'infidélité et des conduites sexuelles
n'ont jamais affecté la popularité de
donald trump
il pourrait en être autrement pour joe
biden qui se présente comme un grand
défenseur des droits des femmes
un écueil en tout cas dont on aurait pu
se passer le candidat démocrate lui qui
a du mal à faire décoller sa campagne
confinées à la maison depuis des
semaines coronavirus hobby ginger bread
& cie jean françois bélanger
radio-canada washington